START AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
WRITING WITH FILE ITEM ONE AB
ONE THIRTY SIX YOU LIKE TO OPEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
AND THIS IS REGULAR ORDER
BUSINESS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- GOOD AFTERNOON AND
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB ONE
THIRTY SIX WHICH I AN INTER DO
STERN RESPONSE TO THE RECENT
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS SCANDAL.
ADMISSIONS TO COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY COMPETITIVE TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE AS STUDY
HIGHLIGHTED THAT AT THIRTY EIGHT
COLLEGES IN THE U. S. INCLUDING
IVY LEAGUE SCHOOLS.
MORE STUDENTS COME FROM THE TOP
1% OF THE INCOME SCALE THEN FROM
THE ENTIRE BOTTOM 60%.
THIS UNDERLIES THAT STUDENTS
FROM LOW TO MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES HAVE EVEN LESS OF A
CHANCE OF BEING ADMITTED TO
THESE TOP COLLEGES.
AND MARCH TWENTY NINETEEN MORE
THAN FIFTY PEOPLE WERE CHARGED
OR INDICTED BY FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS CHARGES RANGE FROM
COLLEGE COACHES ALLEGEDLY PAID
BY BRIBES STANDARDIZE COLLEGE
TESTING ADMINISTRATORS.
WHO WERE PAID FOR A HOST OF
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AND PARENTS WHO
PAID FOR THEIR CHILDREN TO
SECURE IN MISSIONS TO THE BEST
UNIVERSITIES THAT THE UNITED
STATES HAS TO OFFER?
IT'S INVOLVE USED A NUMBER OF
SCHEMES WHICH ALSO VIOLATE
FEDERAL AND STATE TAX LAWS WILL
ALSO REAPING TAX BENEFITS
INCLUDING NUMBER.
ONE USE OF PARENTS BUSINESS TO
INVOICE CONSULTING FEES SO THEY
CAN WRITE IT OFF AS A BUSINESS
EXPENSE.
STOCKTON NATION'S ALLOWED
INDIVIDUALS TO WRITE OFF THE
MARKET VALUE OF THE STOCK.
AS WELL AS AVOIDING PAYING
CAPITAL GAIN TAX ON THE
APPRECIATION OF THE SHARES A
DOUBLE TAX BENEFIT.
NUMBER THREE DIRECT MONETARY
CHARITABLE DONATION ALLOWED
OPPORTUNITY TO WRITE OFF
DONATIONS ON THEIR TAXES.
AB ONE THIRTY SIX WOULD PROHIBIT
A CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTION
DEDUCTION MADE TO POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTION OR THE KEY WORLDWIDE
FOUNDATION AND REQUIRES THOSE
CALIFORNIA.
TAXPAYERS WHO ARE NAMED IN THE
FEDERAL INDICTMENT AND FOUND
GUILTY TO MEND THEIR STATE TAX
RETURNS AND DISCLOSURES FOR
TAXABLE YEARS BEGINNING ON OR
AFTER JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY FOURTEEN THIS CRIMINAL
ACTION HAS VICTIMIZE HARD
WORKING STUDENTS AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WHO WERE DOT DENIED IN
MISSIONS BECAUSE OF THE ACTIONS
OF THOSE INVOLVED AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO DO SO AT THE EXPENSE.
OF CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS.
WE CAN'T LOOK THE OTHER WAY AND
WE NEED TO TAKE ACTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPOR.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING THAT WOULD LIKE TO OPEN
DEVON.
I WOULD AND I GUESS [inaudible]
SORRY.
OKAY WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
I WAS JUST GOING TO ADD THAT
THIS IS ACTUALLY ONE BILL OUT OF
THE PACKAGE RELATED TO THIS.
ADMISSIONS SCANDAL AND AS THIS
CONTINUES THERE CONTINUES TO BE
MORE -- TYPES OF INQUIRE ABOUT
MANY MORE THAT MAY BE INVOLVED
AND SOME HAVE ASKED WILL WILL
THIS REALLY RESULT IN ANY RETURN
TO OUR TAX BASE AND EVEN IF IT'S
A SMALL PERCENTAGE THAT WE GET
BACK.
THAT IS A GOES A LONG WAY AND TO
MAKING SURE THE PUBLIC KNOWS
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN -- VERY --
MANY WAYS THAT OUR SYSTEM WAS
REALLY ATTACKED BY -- THIS TYPE
OF PERSON WHO'S DOWN STARTED
THIS ENTRY INTO COLLEGE AND
THERE'S VERY REPUTABLE --
CANCERS
ACTUALLY BECAUSE WE HAVE A MANY.
CAL STATE FULLERTON IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH HAS BECOME A
BIGGER AND BIGGER COLLEGE --
I'VE MET MANY WHO HELP STUDENTS
THROUGH THE PROCESS -- AND I
THINK THAT NGUYEN FAMILIES AND
AND PARTICULARLY PARENTS KNOW
WHERE TO DRAW THE LINE -- THAT
CERTAINLY GETTING HELP ALONG THE
WAY IS NOT THE PROBLEM IT'S WHEN
YOU BREAK THE LAW.
THANK YOU ARE STILL A
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT WHEN WE DO TAKE
A VOTE THE RECOMMENDATION TO BE
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU
.
GOING TO HEAR FILE FILE ITEM.
TO AB TEN TWENTY SEVEN BY THE
CHAIR.
CANADA'S CAM OF GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
TEN TWENTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
IMPROVE UPON THE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP ESTABLISHED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT GO BIT.
BY ALLOWING THE STATE TO
DIRECTLY INVEST IN HIGH
PERFORMING COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AB TEN TWENTY SEVEN WORKS WITHIN
THE EXISTING CALIFORNIA COMPETES
TAX CREDIT FRAMEWORK BY ALLOWING
TAX PAYERS TO OFFER AN INTEREST
IN OUR TO ALLOW ALLOWING A
TAXPAYER OFTEN AN INTEREST IN
ITS COMPANY AS PART OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS.
THIS PROGRAM IS COMPLETELY
VOLUNTARY AND MADE AT THE
ELECTION OF THE COMPANY.
BY ALLOWING THE STATE TO
CONSIDER THE OWNERSHIP INTEREST
AS ONE OF THE FACTORS IN
EVALUATING APPLICATIONS
COMPANIES THAT ARE UNABLE TO
MAKE INVESTMENTS THAT ARE ON PAR
WITH LARGER COMPANIES WILL HAVE
A BETTER CHANCE OF QUALIFYING
FOR THE PROGRAM.
ALLOWING TO SHARE THE STATE IN
THE SUCCESS OF THE COMPANY WILL
ALSO ALLOW US TO RAISE THE
CAPITAL NEEDED TO MAKE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT IS CURRENTLY
ALLOCATED TO GO BIZ.
IN FACT IF SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED GO BIZ CAN BECOME A
SELF FUNDED PROGRAM AB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN ALLOWS MORE
TAXPAYERS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM AND ALLOWS THE STATE TO
FUND FUTURE INVESTMENTS.
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT WE
WILL BE TAKING THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS AN
APPROPRIATION FOR TIMING PURPOSE --
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
SIERRA.
SEE NON QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
XENON MADAM CHAIR WE JUST FOLLOW
THEIR QUESTION I WILL.
RETIREMENT MORAL.
OFFER VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH.
FILE ITEM.
FOR THIS MCCARTY MISTER
GALLAGHER
.
PROJECT OPEN OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I PRESENT
TO YOU AB FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES GALLAGHER.
IT'S NOT TOO OFTEN THAT HE AND I
PERCENT BILLS -- TOGETHER BUT
THIS TALKS ABOUT.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE IN
BRINGING -- BIPARTISAN SAYS TO
SUPPORT TO THIS ISSUE TODAY.
THIS IS ABOUT THE OPIOID
PREVENTION AND REHABILITATION
ACT AND COMING TOGETHER TO
TACKLE FUNDING FOR THE CRISIS
FACING OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF
FOR FOR WORKING WITH US AND WENT
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT.
I THINK IT'S JUST ONE OF THEM
CORRECT YES THANK YOU AND SO
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY -- WHAT'S
HAPPENED WITH THESE LATEST
AMENDMENT -- WE CLARIFY THAT
OPIOID SOLD DISTRIBUTED IN THE
STATE I WOULD NOT BE DOUBLE
COUNTED -- WE REDUCE THE GOAL TO
FIND FROM ONE HUNDRED MILLION TO
I THINK A MORE -- RESPONSIBLE
NUMBER OF FIFTY MILLION WE
CLARIFIED THE PENALTIES ARE
REDUCE THEM TO MAKE SURE THE NOT --
TO BURDENSOME ON OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WE HAD LANGUAGE
THAT CLARIFY THAT IS IF THERE
ARE LESS OPIOID SOLD THE STATE
AND THE TOTAL AMOUNT THE FUND.
THE FUND WOULD ALSO BE REDUCED
PROPORTIONALLY.
AND LASTLY WE CLARIFIED THAT IF
THERE IS A STATE SETTLEMENT ON
OKAY NO THAT'S I'M SORRY THAT
WOULD BE FOR THE THAT'S DOWN THE
ROAD WE CLARIFY THAT FUNDS WILL
BE GRANTED ON APPLICATION BASIS
TO COUNTIES A NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED.
CLINICS -- BASED UPON NEED NOT
JUST GOING OUT TO COUNTIES THESE
AMENDMENTS WERE ADDED BASED UPON
THE CONCERNS THAT WE HEARD FROM --
THE OPPOSITION SO IT IN SOME
THAT THIS IS BASED ON THE NOTION
THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN PRODUCTS
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE IS A
NEGATIVE EXTERNALITY BORN.
WE KNOW ABOUT THIS WHEN YOU BUY
A MATTRESS -- TV BATTERIES YOU
PAY INTO A STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM.
AS CONSUMERS WE SUPPORT
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
PAYING FOR THESE NEGATIVE
EXTERNALITIES OF CERTAIN
PRODUCTS BRING TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AT THE SAME
MENTALITY OR BRING TO THIS
MEASURE.
THIS BILL REQUIRE THE
MANUFACTURERS OF COURSE
WHOLESALERS THE SELLER
DISTRIBUTE OPENS IN CALIFORNIA.
REPORT THE NUMBERS OF HOW MUCH
ARE SOLD TO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THEN PAY INTO THE
FUND BASED UPON THEIR MARKET
SHARE.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE CASUALTIES OF
THE NEED FOR THIS THE NUMBERS
ARE ALARMING THE EPIDEMIC
IMPACTS ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE NUMBER OF OF COURSE --
OVERDOSES AND GAS AND IMPACTS ON
FAMILIES BUT ALSO THE IMPACTED
TAXPAYERS WE KNOW THAT.
EVERY TIME INDIVIDUAL GOES TO AN
E. R. THAT'S ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY IT'S BORN UPON THE
TAXPAYER TO PAY FOR THIS.
AND THIS -- PROPOSALS BASED UPON
THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT TODAY
WERE ALL PAYING FOR IT BUT IT
SHOULDN'T LARGELY BE BORN ON THE
BACKS OF TAXPAYERS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE INDUSTRY
MUST STEP UP AND BE A PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
A COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE ARE
FILING LAWSUITS AGAINST
MANUFACTURES NORTH WHOLESALERS
TO FOCUS ON ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS TO BE ANOTHER -- MEASURE --
WE'RE PROUD OF OUR CURRENT
STATEWIDE EFFORTS TO DRAW DOWN A
FEDERAL FUNDING TO FIGHT THIS
EPIDEMIC BUT AS OUR WITNESSES
WILL TESTIFY.
A MORE IS NEEDED PLUS THE
FEDERAL MONEY WILL EXPIRE IN
TWENTY TWENTY THE YEAR THE
REVENUES FROM THIS MEASURE COME
INTO A FAX A VERY TIMELY.
WE NEED A FINANCIAL PLAN TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND OUR CURRENT
EFFORTS -- THIS MEASURE WILL
PROVIDE OUR CLINICS IN PROVIDERS
WITH CRITICAL RESOURCES NEEDED
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES BUT
FIRST LET ME ALLOW.
MY A JOINT AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER TO PRESENT.
CAN CAN WE JUST PAUSE FOR A
MINUTE WE HAVE A QUORUM MISS
HAVING WE CALL THE ROLL -- GROW.
CHU GRAY MAYES.
WELL IN THIS [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
QUIRK.
RIVAS HERE KING.
WE HAVE A QUORUM THIS GALLAGHER
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- YOU
KNOW AS AS WE ALL KNOW IN THIS
ROOM THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC IS A
PRESSING PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT REALLY
THROUGHOUT THE NATION AND THIS
IS SOMETHING IS BEING TALKED
ABOUT AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT.
DRUG TEST ESPECIALLY THOSE
ASSOCIATED WITH PRESCRIPTION
OPIOID DRUGS ARE RISING FASTER
THAN EVER.
AND ARE NOW THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH AMONG AMERICANS UNDER THE
AGE OF FIFTY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN A
LONG. SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE
DIED FROM DRUG OVERDOSES THIS IS
THE LARGEST ANNUAL JUMP EVER.
RECORDED THESE NUMBERS ARE
STAGGERING.
AND I'M HERE TO GIVE YOU A
PERSPECTIVE FROM FROM THE RURAL
AREAS HOW THIS IS IMPACTING US --
IT'S ESPECIALLY HITTING RURAL
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA VERY HARD --
DRUG OVERDOSE DEATHS ARE ALSO
THE MOST COMMON IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SOME REAL COUNTIES
HAVE MORE OPIOID PRESCRIPTIONS.
THAN PEOPLE.
IN BUTTE COUNTY ALONE THERE OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED PRESCRIPTIONS
PER ONE THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH -- WE HAVE A AND M. M. E.
RATE -- AT EIGHTEEN HUNDRED PER
RESIDENT ANNUALLY THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE IS.
SIX HUNDRED FORTY SO WE ARE
DEALING WITH A HUGE CRISIS ON
OUR HANDS AND AND RIGHT NOW AND
THE REASON WHY I HAVE COME ON IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND WHY I THINK IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED IS MY LOCALS ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE HOLDING THIS BURDEN
ALONE -- IT'S IT'S MY IT'S MY
SHERIFF'S IT'S MY HEALTH PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS IT'S MY
HOSPITALS -- THAT HAVE THE
HIGHEST OVER OVERDOSE ADMISSION
RATES -- THAT IS COSTING
EVERYBODY MORE MONEY AND ALL I'M
REALLY ASKING FOR ALL THAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR IS THAT THE
MANUFACTURERS WHO HELPED CREATE
THIS CRISIS.
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION -- AND
THAT'S WHAT AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT TRULY DOESN'T ABOUT
PUNISHING ANYBODY.
IT'S ABOUT SAYING TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS FOR THIS
CRISIS THAT WERE ALL THAT WELL
FACING WE'VE ALL GOT SKIN IN THE
GAME AND WE'VE WE'VE PASSED LAWS
TO GET OUT PRESCRIPTIONS.
AND TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUES THE
ABUSES WE WERE SEEN AMONG
DOCTORS AND OTHERS RIGHT WE WE
HAVE WE HAVE TRIED TO EXPAND --
THE ABILITY TO PRESCRIBE.
MEDICATIONS THAT WILL HELP GET
PEOPLE OFF OF OPIOIDS -- WE TRY
TO REMOVE THOSE BARRIERS BUT WE
NEED THE FUNDING.
FEDERAL FUNDING HAS STARTED TO
DWINDLE OFF FOR THIS WE'RE GONNA
NEED THE FUN IN LONG TERM TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
TREATMENT.
NOW THERE'S A SPOKEN HUB.
MODEL THIS WORKING VERY WELL BUT
IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO NEED
FUNDING GOING FORWARD SO AGAIN
THIS IS A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
FUND NOW WE'VE WE'VE MADE THAT
AMENDMENT -- THEY WERE TRYING
THAT WE'RE SEEKING TO GET THE
MANUFACTURERS TO BE TO BE PART
OF WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH INDUSTRY.
AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY
AND GET REAL SOLUTIONS HERE --
AND SO YOU KNOW I JUST ASK FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE ON OUR HANDS --
AND THAT THAT REALLY WE NEED THE
RESOURCES WE ARE TOTALLY.
ELIZA NEVER RESOURCE WE HAVE
AVAILABLE AND AND IT IS VERY
TOUGH AND I DO HAVE A WITH US
TODAY TO HELP TESTIFY ARE ARE
COUNTY SHERIFF -- FROM BUTTE
COUNTY.
COR HONEY SHOULD BE JOIN US AS
WELL.
I'M NOT SURE IF COME ON UP.
HI WITNESSES THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- THE COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE IT AS YOU KNOW MY
NAME IS COREY HOW AND THE
SHERIFF OF YOU COUNTY AND I'M A
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JUST AS A QUICK FAQ IS IN A OF
OF THINGS DO.
A RECENT STUDY BIãU CAN IS THE
FIFTH WORST OPIATE OVERDOSE
DEATH RATE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
AND NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS THAT ARE.
NOT CREATE A PROBLEM -- WE NOW
ARE STARTING TO SEE A FICTITIOUS
OXYCONTIN PILLS MADE OUT OF
FENNEL.
ARE BEING BROUGHT INTO THE
COUNTY AND I THINK THAT
ILLUSTRATES.
HOW SIGNIFICAN THE PROBLEM IS?
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO
PROVIDE TREATMENT TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ADDICTED THIS I THINK
WOULD BE HELPFUL AND SO THAT'S
WHY I'M IN SUPPORT OF IT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANKS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW THE
WHOLE CENTER PERSPECTIVE ON A.
B. FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT MY NAME
IS ALLEY PRETENDS AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF QUALITY AT
THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION.
THE STATE RIGHT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
CLINICS AND HEALTH CENTERS THAT
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
COMPREHENSIVE CARE TO SIX POINT
NINE MILLION CALIFORNIANS EACH
YEAR.
WE ARE IS PROUD TO SUPPORT AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT AND WE
BELIEVE THAT ALL PLAN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
EXPAND TREATMENT FOR OPIOID USE
DISORDER.
THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC CONTINUES TO
DEVASTATE CALIFORNIA ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH 70% OF OPIOID
RELATED OVERDOSE DEATHS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN INVOLVED
PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CENTERS ARE DEEPLY INVESTED IN
EXPANDING ACCESS TO TREATMENT
FOR A PURE DOES USE DISORDER
INCLUDING EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES LIKE INTEGRATED
MEDICATIONS IS TO TREATMENT OR
AM.
EIGHTEEN WHICH COMBINES
MEDICATIONS COMPLEMENTED BY A
RANGE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS.
AND HEALTH CENTERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE AMONG THE PRIMARY
PROVIDERS OF OUTPATIENT
MEDICATIONS IS TO TREATMENT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN
HEALTH CENTERS OF NEARLY DOUBLED
THE NUMBER OF CLINICIANS LICENSE
TO PRESCRIBE MEDICINES. FOR
OPIOID ADDICTION YES HEALTH
CENTERS CONTINUE TO FACE
CHALLENGES IN SUSTAINING THE
SERVICES WITH EXISTING PAYMENT
STRUCTURES.
THE REMIX REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM
IS SIMPLY NOT DESIGNED FOR THE
INTENSIVE CARE MANAGEMENT FAMILY
SUPPORT AND COMMUNITY PREVENTION
AND EDUCATION THAT IS NEEDED.
HEALTH CENTERS RELY ON GRANTS TO
SUSTAIN THE SUPPORT OF STAFF AND
SERVICES NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE
OUTCOMES.
THE HIGH COST BUT LOW
REIMBURSEMENT IS A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE TO THE FULL ADOPTION
OF MHC ACROSS THE STATE.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY
CREATING THE OPIATE PREVENTION
AND REHABILITATION PROGRAM FUND
WILL PROVIDE A MECHANISM TO
SUSTAINABLE ONGOING FUNDING TO
CONTINUE AND EXPAND LOCAL
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE OPIOID
CRISIS.
THROUGH COMPETITIVE GRANTS TO
HIGH NEED COMMUNITIES
FURTHERMORE THE INFORMATION
PROPOSED TO BE DISCLOSED BY THE
MANUFACTURER OR WHOLESALER AS
OUTLINED IN THIS ACT.
WOULD BE INVALUABLE TO
UNDERSTANDING THE AVAILABILITY
OF PROBLEMATIC OPIOIDS.
WE CAN UNDERSTAND OR MEETING
FULLY IT TACKLE THE SCOPE OF THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING THE BREATH OF THE
SUPPLY CHAINS IMPACT.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY ON AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION I'M NOT GONNA REPEAT
THE THE STATEMENTS MADE BY THE
AUTHORS ABOUT THE EXTENT OF THE
OPIOID CRISIS YOU ALL KNOW HOW
IT'S DEVASTATING YOUR
COMMUNITIES.
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT -- ONE ADD
ONE THING THAT ACCORDING TO THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION THREE OUT OF FOUR
HEROIN USERS BEGAN THEIR
ADDICTION BY MISS USING
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
DESPITE THE CLAIMS MADE BY SOME
COMPANIES THAT THESE OPIOID --
PRESCRIPTIONS ARE NON ADDICTIVE
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE ON DRUG
ABUSE ESTIMATES THAT UP 225% OF
PEOPLE WHO BEGIN USING
PRESCRIPTION PAIN PILLS OVER THE
LONG TERM BECOME ADDICTED TO
THESE MEDICATIONS.
ARE IN OUR WHAT IT WANTED JUST
ADDRESS QUICKLY ONE AND
STATEMENT THAT WAS MADE IN THE
ANALYSIS ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY
OF FEDERAL FUNDING AND YES
CALIFORNIA HAS RECEIVED.
MONEY THROUGH THE FEDERAL CURES
ACT.
THESE ARE GRANT FUNDS THAT HAVE
COME THAT HAVE ENABLED US TO
ESTABLISH A HUB AND SPOKE -- A
MODEL SYSTEM FOR PCA FOR
EXPANDING ACCESS TO MEDICATIONS
FOR ADDICTION TREATMENT -- IN IN
MANY AREAS OF CALIFORNIA AND YET --
IT'S FAR FROM CERTAIN THAT THIS
FEDERAL FUNDING IS GOING TO
CONTINUE THE PROBLEM WITH
FEDERAL GRANTS -- WELL WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE MONEY IT'S IT'S
IT'S THAT INEVITABLY WHEN THIS --
MONEY GOES AWAY AND THIS IS TRUE
THIS IS TIME LIMITED THEN THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE TO BE ABLE TO TO
SHOW THAT THEY CAN SUSTAIN BE
SUSTAINED OTHERWISE IF IF THE
GRANT MONEY GOES AWAY.
AND THEY CAN'T BE SUSTAINED AND
THEN WE LOSE THOSE PROGRAMS AND
THAT WOULD BE REALLY UNFORTUNATE
SO WE THINK THAT FUNDING
AVAILABLE THROUGH THIS.
THROUGH THIS BILL WOULD BE ABLE
TO SUSTAIN THESE GOOD PROGRAMS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT -- NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
AND I'M CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT
HARRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE.
THIS IS A LONG TERM PROBLEM THIS
IS A LONG TERM SOLUTION ONCE
PEOPLE ARE ADDICTED THEY DON'T
GET OVER RIGHT AWAY.
SO.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE GIVING THE
TREATMENT SO THAT PEOPLE GET.
CLEAN AND SOBER.
THANK YOU.
NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BETSEY
ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS OR TRANSPORT.
MON COSTA BLOCK CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE RETIRED AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA AS OPPOSED TO OTHER
STATES THE AGE GROUP WITH THE
HIGHEST DEATH RATE DUE TO
OPIOIDS IS FIFTY FIVE AND OVER.
THIS IS A CRISIS AND WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IT.
THANK YOU.
NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE
FOLKS.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DAMON AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE.
MANAGER ONLINE.
WE HAVE FOR THE COUNTY OF
HUMBOLDT IN SPORT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. FOR GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME'S MARIN WILSON I
REPRESENT A GROUP OF SENIOR HOME
CARE GIVERS AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. FOURTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE THOSE WHO ARE OF STE.
TEST BY AMERICA.
WHAT DOES HOLD ON ONE SECOND
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS LET --
THESE FOLKS TESTIFY AND THEN
WE'LL WE'LL TAKE YOU IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
CHAIRMAN BURKE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LEAH
LINDAHL AND THE SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF STATE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR
THE HEALTH CARE DISTRIBUTION
ALLIANCE.
A SHE IS THE NATIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING PRIMARY
PHARMACEUTICAL WHOLESALE
DISTRIBUTORS -- WHOLESALE
DISTRIBUTORS ARE THE VITAL LINK
IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN CONNECTING
PHARMACEUTICAL MANUFACTURERS TO
ROUGHLY SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
POINTS OF CARE SO PHARMACIES
HOSPITALS NURSING HOMES.
HOSPICE CENTERS THAT CENTER
ACROSS CALIFORNIA -- WE'RE HERE
TODAY AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THE
LEGISLATION AS A MODELED AFTER
NEW YORK FATHER WAS RULED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IT WOULD CREATE
AN ARBITRARY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS SURCHARGE ON PHYSICIAN
PRESCRIBE OPIOID TREATMENT THE
MEDICATION.
IN THE FEDERAL JUDGE'S DECISION
IT WAS MADE CLEAR THE PLACING A
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL ASSESSMENT
UNLIKELY ORDERED AND PRESCRIBE
MEDICATIONS AS ILL CONCEIVED.
AND COULD WILL REDUCE THE
AVAILABILITY OF OPIOID
MEDICATIONS FOR THOSE WHO
CRITICALLY NEED THEM -- THE
SURCHARGE TARGETS MEDICATIONS
NOT JUST DOWN IN MEDICS MEDICINE
CABINETS BUT ALSO THOSE NEEDED
BY PATIENTS UNDER THE CARE OF
LICENSE MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
INCLUDING THOSE UNDERGOING
SURGICAL PROCEDURES CANCER
PATIENTS SEEKING TO REDUCE PAIN.
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING END OF
LIFE CARE -- IN THOSE OF
DEBILITATING PAINFUL CONDITIONS
WHO ARE TRYING TO LIVE A NORMAL
EVERYDAY LIFE HOW FOR EXAMPLE
LIKE A MOTHER GOING INTO IT --
LABOR AND DELIVERY AND THAT BUT
DURRELL IS AN OPIOID PRODUCT
THAT WOULD INCREASE IN COST --
ULTIMATELY LIVING A SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL ASSESSMENT ON OPIOID
PRODUCTS WOULD IMPOSE A COSTLY
BURDEN ON THE PHARMACEUTICAL
SUPPLY CHAIN AND ON THE PATIENTS
PROVIDERS AND PHARMACIES.
AND WHICH IT SERVICE THE
PROPOSAL DOES NOTHING TO ADDRESS
THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE EPIDEMIC.
AND NORMAL TO DECREASE THE
NUMBER OF OPIOIDS IT WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
INSTEAD RAISES THE COST BASED ON
THE CURRENT DEMAND.
BASIC ECONOMICS IN THE RECENT
COURT DECISION OVERTURNED THE
NEW YORK Là CONCLUDED THAT COST
INCREASES IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
AND SHE WILL INEVITABLY BE
SHARED BY CONSUMERS.
AT THE TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA'S
MAKING MANY POLICY STEPS TO
ADDRESS THE COST OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS.
IT SEEMS COUNTER PRODUCTIVE TO
PLACE A NOTABLE SO ON THE SAME
PRODUCTS WERE TRYING TO CONTROL
COSTS OF SO IT'S J. THEREFORE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
OPPOSE THE LEGISLATION
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL.
AFTERNOON MANAGER MEMBERS
PROMOTION WITH THE ASSOCIATION
FOR ACCESSIBLE MEDICINES AM
REPRESENTS THE GENERIC.
AND BIOSIMILAR MANUFACTURERS --
WE'RE ALSO POSED A A A MEMBERS
ARE ACUTELY AWARE OF THE
ADDICTIVE NATURE OF THESE
PRODUCTS -- IS PRECISELY THESE
REASONS THAT THERE IS A HIGHER
LEVEL OF SCRUTINY APPLY TO THEM
BY THE FDA AND THEY ARE HIGHLY
REGULATED ALSO BY THE D. E. A..
EIGHTY A MEMBER SUPPORT THIS
OVERSIGHT [inaudible]
AND AND THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT HIM THEY HAVE
BEEN PUT IN PLACE I THINK. ONE
OF THE THINGS FOR THE GENERIC
MANUFACTURERS -- IS THE MARKET
PLACES CHANGED SINCE THIS REALLY
BECAME A CRISIS.
IN WHAT.
MOST OF THE LAWSUITS THAT HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED -- ARE TYPICALLY
THE THE PHARMACISTS THE ARMS AND
THE BRAND MANY FACTORS THAT ARE
NAMED.
AMERICAN FACTORS NOW MAKE ABOUT
ARMS ARE ABOUT 90% OF ALL THE
PRESCRIPTIONS NOW OR ARE GENERIC.
SO THE MARKET PLACES MOVED FROM
WHAT WAS A BRAND PRODUCT.
GENERIC MANUFACTURERS DON'T
MARKET.
THEY DID NOT DO DIRECTOR
PRESCRIBER -- DETAILING.
THEN IT'S TRULY THE ACCESS FOR
PATIENTS WHO ARE IN NEED BECAUSE
THESE ARE IMPORTANT PRODUCTS FOR
MANY MANY PATIENTS.
WHETHER IT'S END OF LIFE CARE
CANCER -- INTRACTABLE PAIN MANY
PATIENTS STILL NEED THESE.
AND BECAUSE OPIATES ARE NOW A
VERY.
HIGH -- VERY LOW MARGIN PRODUCT
BUT RELY ON A HIGH VOLUME.
THE FEES THAT COULD BE CHARGED --
ACCORDING TO THIS BILL ARE OFTEN
GOING TO BE MORE THAN
MANUFACTURERS ACTUALLY MAKE AN
REVENUE ONE MANUFACTURES DURING
THE NEW YORK -- CASE IT'S BEEN
BEEN REFERENCED A COUPLE OF
TIMES TESTIFIED THAT THE AMOUNT
OF THE FEE WAS TRULY MORE THAN.
THE REVENUE.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS IN ANY
INDUSTRY IN ANY PRODUCT?
MANUFACTURER CAN NOT STAY IN
BUSINESS.
AND THAT'S WHAT IS GOING TO
REDUCE THE ACCESS OR INCREASE
THE COST FOR THOSE WHO DO REMAIN.
WITHIN.
THE THIS MARKET PLACE THE WAY
THAT THE BILL IS STRUCTURED IF
ANYONE MANUFACTURER PULLS OUT.
THEN HE OTHER MANUFACTURERS
THAT ARE LEFT ARE GONNA BE
HIRING PAYING A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF OF THE FEE.
BECAUSE OF THOSE REASONS THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO DRIVE EITHER THE
COSTS OF WAR THE ACCESS DOWN.
NOT ALL PRODUCTS ARE AVAILABLE
FROM MULTIPLE MANUFACTURERS
EITHER SOME OF THEM --
ESPECIALLY -- INJECTABLE
MEDICINES AT HOSPITALS.
ONLY HAVE ONE OR TWO
MANUFACTURERS AND WHEN THE THE
COSTS OF PAYING THIS FEE OR TAX.
GO UP IS GOING TO BE IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THOSE MANUFACTURERS TO
REMAIN IN THE MARKETING
CALIFORNIA.
ALSO THIS IS A NATIONAL
MARKETPLACE WE DON'T SELL.
PRODUCTS DIRECTLY TO CALIFORNIA
WE SELL PRIMARILY TO THREE
WHOLESALERS WHO.
PURCHASED 90% OF ALL GENERIC
DRUGS.
WE DON'T CONTROL THE AS
MANUFACTURERS WHERE THOSE GO WE
DON'T NECESSARILY EVEN KNOW
THEY'VE THEM WITH THE
MANUFACTURE THE WHOLESALERS --
REQUEST A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
UNITS THAT'S WHERE WE SELL THEM
SO WE DON'T NECESSARILY A DIRECT
THEM INTO CALIFORNIA.
WE DON'T MARKET THEM WITHIN --
WE DON'T PRESCRIBE THEM WE'RE
NOT THE INSURANCE COMPANIES THAT
LIMIT THE ALTERNATIVE CARE OR
TREATMENT MODALITIES THAT MANY
PATIENTS COULD FACE -- AND AND
BECAUSE OF THOSE REASONS --
WORRY OR IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
COME ON UP.
THANK YOU LORRAINE JOSEPH DOBSON
AND I RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE A. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT I'M NOT
ELDER CARE SPECIALIST.
THANK YOU.
JEREMY WILSON AND I OPPOSE AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT HEALTH CARE
SPECIALIST [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- GLAM BROWN CARE
PROVIDER I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
OPPOSITION OF AB.
ONE FOUR SIX EIGHT I'M MORE
MONTESSORI -- AND I OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S TIM POLIO
WOULD BE A NIGHTMARE BET.
FEEL THAT FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH IS PASSED COSTS ON TO THE
CONSUMER.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AUTUMN OGDEN
SMITH WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK
ALSO REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHICKENS WITH
CROWLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN OPPOSITION.
SECOND QUARTER -- CALIFORNIA
DOWN THE CESSATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. EIGHT MANY HERE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LICENSES ASIAN IN
OPPOSITION.
SERRA -- WITH CAL CHAMBER
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
MARIN HIGGINS ON BEHALF OF BILE
COMMON OPPOSITION.
ALLEN JR MEMBERS PAUL GLAD BILL
TMB OF THE PHARMACEUTICAL
RESEARCH MANUFACTURERS SUPPOSED.
PETER CALLOUS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION BECAUSE HOSPICES A
CAPITATED BENEFIT AND IS AT RISK
FOR ALL THE COSTS PROVIDED TO
THE TERMINALLY ILL.
COST INCREASES -- FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THE TAX WILL BE BORNE
BY THE HOSPICE PROGRAMS AND WILL
COMPROMISE THE CARE IS PROVIDED
THE TERMLY ELEANOR AND UNHAPPILY
OPPOSED.
THINK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MACHAR RIVAS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION WHILE WE APPRECIATE
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR
TRYING TO DO WE DO BELIEVE THAT
PHARMACISTS WILL BEAR THE COST
OF THIS TAX AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO BOAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
JUST IN REGARDS TO I VOTED NO ON
THIS -- IN HEALTH COMMITTEE
COURSES IS REVENUE TAX -- AND
HAD SOME CONVERSATIONS OVER THE
WEEKEND.
AND I STRUGGLE A LOT -- WITH --
THESE THINGS FROM A
PHILOSOPHICAL PERSPECTIVE WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT IS.
A VOTED NO ON THE TOBACCO TAX --
EVEN THOUGH I DON'T LIKE TOBACCO --
PAID THE DIDN'T SUPPORT THE
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGE TAX ON
EVEN THOUGH I KNOW THE
INCREDIBLE DAMAGE.
OTHER THAT SAID DOING TO TO TO
PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND WE KNOW THE IMPACT THAT BOMB
THAT OPIOIDS ARE HAVING ON OUR
SOCIETY.
AND SO THE QUESTION THAT I HAVE
IS IF IT'S NOT A TAX TO BE ABLE
TO BRING IN SOME REVENUE TO BE
ABLE.
TO HELP FUND SOME PROGRAMS AND
WHAT IS THE ANSWER CITY
OPPOSITION THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE
HERE SPEAKING FOR THE OPPOSITION
WHAT IS THE ANSWER -- TO BE ABLE
TO SOLVE BECAUSE IT IS HAVING A
MAJOR IMPACT.
ON PEOPLE'S LIVES AND AT SOME
LEVEL I THINK THOSE WHO ARE
PRODUCING OF THIS PRODUCT THERE
IS SOME LEVEL OF RESPONSIBILITY
THAT'S THERE.
SO IF NOT THIS THEN WHAT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
IT'S A A. M. -- DOES BELIEVE
OBVIOUSLY THAT THERE IS AN ISSUE
WITH THIS -- A. M. HAS SUPPORTED
ELEMENTS -- PERSON.
LIMITS ON THE PRESCRIBING -- AND
THAT'S REALLY WHERE THE CONTROL
OF WHERE THESE DRUGS COME FROM
THE MANUFACTURERS SIMPLY FILL
ORDERS [inaudible]
AND WHILE.
THE NUMBER OF DRUGS THAT ARE ARE
BEING -- SOLD OR DISTRIBUTED OR
OR PASSED THROUGH PHARMACIES.
THEY ALL TAKE A PRESCRIPTION --
THERE'S EDUCATION OF THE
PHYSICIANS OR THE PRESCRIBER
SEWER WRITING THE DRUGS.
ADDITIONAL EDUCATION OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE TAKING THE DRUGS.
HOW TO DISPOSE OF THEM PROPERLY?
HELL.
TO NOT TAKE THEM BEYOND WHAT
THEIR PHYSICIAN ORDERS ARE --
WHETHER IT'S THAT THE USE OF PDM
PEAS TO STOP ANY OF THE ILLEGAL --
DISTRIBUTION WHETHER IT COMES
FROM THE MANUFACTURER FROM THE
WHOLESALER -- BEING STOLEN FROM
A PILL MILK OR FROM A PHARMACY
OR PATIENTS WHO ARE DOCTOR
SHOPPING.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
STEPS OUR CONCERN AGAIN IS JUST
THE WAY THAT THAT THIS FEE IS
STRUCTURED NOT THAT.
THERE'S NOT A PROBLEM.
BUT THE WAY THAT THAT THE TAXES
IS BEING DONE AND WILL FOCUS ON
WE BELIEVE ON THE ON THE ON THE
MANUFACTURER'S EVEN THOUGH.
AGAIN WE'RE JUST FILLING IN
ORDER THAT THAT'S BASED ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL SALE -- SO WE
DON'T EVEN CONTROL WE DON'T KNOW
THE PHARMACY THAT.
IS -- PERHAPS PRESCRIBING -- OR
I'M SORRY DISTRIBUTING MORE
PILLS THEN THERE ARE PEOPLE
WITHIN THE TOWN OR THE PHYSICIAN
THAT'S WRITING.
UP MORE SCRIPTS THAN PATIENTS IN
THE REGION -- AND THOSE ARE
OTHER ASPECTS THAT CAN BE DONE
IN ARE BEING DONE -- AND
THROUGHOUT THE NATION REALLY --
TO HELP ADDRESS THE PROBLEM BUT
SIMPLY PUTTING A TAX ON A
PRODUCT JUST IS GOING TO
INCREASE THE COST OF THE PRODUCT
AND FOR CLARIFICATION SOME
LIMITING BILLS HAVE NOT MADE IT
OUT OF THIS HOUSE IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS SO LIKE PRESCRIPTION
LIMITS FOR CHILDREN WAS NOT.
DID IT MAKE IT OUT OF THE SENATE
LAST YEAR SO NOT ALL LIMITING
BILLS AND NOT ARE ARE REALLY
BEING PASSED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO FOR CLARITY FOR
THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATRONIZE.
FOLLOW UP QUESTION FOR YOU I'M
DO YOU KNOW.
SAID SO YOU'RE ASSOCIATION
ACCESSIBLE MEDICINE DO YOU KNOW.
HOW MUCH PROFIT YOUR MEMBERS
MADE FROM THE SALE OF OPIATES IN?
TWENTY EIGHTEEN YOU KNOW QUITE
HONESTLY THAT'S ONE OF THE THE
BENEFITS OF WORKING FOR AN
ASSOCIATION IS I DO NOT NEED TO
KNOW THAT AND I I HONESTLY I
DON'T.
I CAN SAY THAT WHICH IS ACTUALLY
A VERY SMALL MARGIN ARM SORRY A
SMALL PORTION OF THE BROADER --
GENERIC MARKET PLACE MANY
MANUFACTURERS DON'T PARTICIPATE
IN THE OPIOID MARKET AT ALL --
WE DO KNOW THAT THE NUMBER OF OF
PILLS THAT ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED
OR IT'S ACTUALLY CONTROLLED BY
THE D. E. A. R. MANUFACTURERS
CAN'T MAKE ANY MORE PILLS THAN
WHAT THE D. E. A. AUTHORIZES
EACH YEAR.
THAT NUMBER'S BEEN DROPPING
PRETTY PRECIPITOUSLY OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS AS I RECALL IT'S
ABOUT 25% LOWER THAN IT WAS A
COUPLE YEARS AGO -- IT'S BUT AS
FAR AS THE EXACT REVENUE NOW I
DON'T KNOW -- BUT IT IS A SMALL
MARGIN DRUGS -- MEANING THAT
THERE'S MANY COMPETITORS MAKING
THE EXACT SAME PRODUCT.
OKAY.
NOT NOT NECESSARILY YOUR GROUP
OF THE ASSOCIATION MEMBERS BUT
AS A WHOLE THE INDUSTRY IS
MAKING AND HAS MADE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IS THAT CORRECT -- I I I
CAN'T ANSWER THAT WITH ENOUGH
CLARITY -- YOU KNOW WE CAN LOOK
INTO IT BUT I I THINK I WOULD GO
BACK TO MY COMMENTS EARLIER THAT
THE MARKET PLACES CHANGE PRETTY
PRECIPITOUSLY.
SINCE THE BRANDS -- HAVE LOST
PATENT PROTECTION AND IT HAS
BECOME PRIMARILY A GENERIC
PRODUCT.
OKAY AND THAT WAS TO MY PROFIT
SIDE OF THE QUESTION.
DON'T ASK MUCH ABOUT THAT THE
COST SO THEY WE ALL KNOW THAT.
THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC IS EXACT IS
AT EXACT TEAM.
TREMENDOUS HUMAN CALL.
AND WOULD YOU ALSO AGREE THAT IT
IS EXACTING A TREMENDOUS
FINANCIAL TOLL.
ON CALIFORNIAN CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY.
YEAH I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
DISCREPANCY ON THAT -- I THINK
PART OF THE QUESTION THOUGH IT
REMAINS AND I THINK THE SHERIFF
ACTUALLY BROUGHT IT UP THE FACT
THAT THE USE OF OF ILLEGAL
FENNEL.
AND NOT FROM PRESCRIBED DRUGS IS
ON THE RISE AND THAT IS ONE OF
THE MAIN AREAS THAT I THINK
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IN THIS
BILL WILL DO NOTHING. TO ADDRESS
THE INCREASED USE OF OF FENNEL
THAT IS NOT COMING THROUGH THE
NORMAL DISTRIBUTION CHANNEL
THERE HAVE BEEN LAWSUITS -- AND
THOSE IN ON OUR VIEW SHOULD
CONTINUE -- WHETHER IT'S AGAINST
THE PILL MILLS THE PHYSICIANS
WHO ARE OVER PRESCRIBING OR IF
THERE ARE MANUFACTURERS THAT OR
OR DISTRIBUTING THEM THAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE VENUE BUT AGAIN I
DON'T THINK THAT.
TAXING THIS PRODUCT IS REALLY
GOING TO END UP REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF DRUGS THAT IS COMING
THROUGH THE LEGAL.
PRESCRIPTION SUPPLY CHAIN.
BUT I THINK I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THERE'S THERE'S MUCH THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE THE SPACING I
THINK.
THE OBJECT OF THIS SPELL IS TO
RAISE SOME RESOURCES TO FIND
DESPERATELY NEEDED TREATMENTS --
CONSERVE GETTING BACK TO MY
QUESTION THINK THE ANSWER IS IT
IS IT'S IT'S COSTING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
AND I THINK TO THE AUTHOR'S
POINT.
IT'S REGULAR TAXPAYERS IT'S IT'S
OUR CONSTITUENTS.
YOU KNOW ALL ACROSS THE STATE WE
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE PICKING UP
THE TAB.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK.
MY COLLEAGUES TO THE RIGHT RAISE
THE QUESTION ABOUT KIND OF THE
PHILOSOPHICAL APPROACH AND THAT
THIS IS BEEN A TOUGH ONE FOR ME
AS WELL SO I'M PRO BUSINESS AND
PRO TAX PAYER.
I LOOK VERY CLOSELY AT THE IDEA
OF ANY ADDITIONAL FEE BUT I
THINK.
THAT I'M WHEN I LOOK AT THE THE
TOLL THAT IS BEING EXACTED --
ALL ACROSS.
YOU KNOW MY COMMUNITY ALL ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND IT FEELS TO ME LIKE.
MY TAXPAYERS OF MY CONSTITUENTS
ARE THE ONLY ONES WERE REPAIRING
THE BIRD AND I DO FEEL LIKE THE
INDUSTRY.
NEEDS TO STEP UP AND THAT'S NOT
TO SAY THAT EVERYONE.
IN THE INDUSTRY IS IN A BEEN A
BAD ACTOR BUT NO.
WHETHER IT'S BEEN THROUGH
HAPPENSTANCE OR OR OR SOMETHING
YOU KNOW MORE NEFARIOUS.
THERE HAS BEEN A CRISIS IT'S
BEEN CREATED AND I I DO THINK
THAT THE INDUSTRY NEEDS TO COME
TO THE TABLE INTERNIST AND I'VE
FOR THAT REASON YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK THIS.
IT'S A PERFECT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BUT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY AND HAVE NO
ONE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE
CAN MOVE THIS FORWARD SO THAT WE
CAN.
CAN HAVE A SERIOUS CONVERSATION
AT ALL THE THINGS THAT NEED TO
BE DONE BECAUSE THE BOTTOM LINE
IS EVERYTHING YOU TALKED ABOUT.
IN A BETTER EDUCATION BETTER
ENFORCEMENT.
THAT STUFF COSTS MONEY AND RIGHT
NOW CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ARE THE
ONES HE'S PAYING FOR IT AND WE
NEED.
WE NEED HELP TO GET THIS GET
THIS DONE [inaudible]
MR GREAT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OR
BRING IN FORWARD.
AN INTERESTING TOPIC AND I'LL
CERTAINLY GIVE YOU ACCOLADES FOR
THE BOTH OF YOU HAVE -- LOBBIED
ME HEAVILY.
ON THIS BILL AND MADE -- BEEN
GOOD ADVOCATES FOR YOUR ISSUE --
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH I WANT TO
COVER HONESTLY -- YOUR WHATEVER
LOOK AT BILL IT'S KIND OF THE
THREE BASIC TENETS LIKE IS THERE
A PROBLEM.
I THINK WE CAN EASILY ANSWER
THAT QUESTION -- IN THIS CASE IS
A HUGE PROBLEM.
IS A PROBLEM GOVERNMENT COULD
SOLVE.
CERTAINLY I THINK GOVERNMENT'S
ROLE.
DOES THE BILL PROPOSED HAVE ANY
OF THOSE SOLUTIONS ANDRIGHT
THAT'S THE THIRD QUESTION
[inaudible]
AND YOUR STRIKES ME.
IT MAY THIS COULD BE A PIECE OF
THE PROBLEM I CERTAINLY DON'T
THINK THIS IS THE ENTIRE PUZZLE.
FOR NINETEEN YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN AROUND THIS INSTITUTION.
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN
THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY.
SHOW UP IN A TO SOME DEGREE CRY
POOR MOUTH.
I SAW YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
ALMOST BROKE OTHER THAN THE
PHARMACOGNOSY SAY WERE MAKING
LOTS OF MONEY BUT WE NEED FOR
OUR DE.
EVERYBODY ELSE IS GOING BROKE
MEANWHILE WE SPEND MORE ON
HEALTH CARE PER CAPITA THAN MOST
OTHER COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD.
WHEN WE VOTED LAST YEAR?
ON SB SEVENTY IN THE THE
TRANSPARENCY BILL.
YOUR VARIETY OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
IN THAT WROTE LETTERS TO MY
OFFICE.
ARGUING THAT -- IS -- KAISER
PERMANENTE.
OUR ARGUE THE MUCH THE GREATEST
THREATS AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE IS
THE FIRM'S CORNISH PRICING OF
NEW AND EXISTING MEDICATION --
LEADING TO HIGHER COSTS --
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS TO
RISING PRESCRIPTION DRUGS HAVE
BEEN SIZE A MAJOR DRIVER OF
PREMIUM INCREASE WE GO ON AND ON
AND ON AND ASK THE SERVER ARE WE
SETTING OURSELVES UP FOR ANOTHER.
COST DRIVER AND THE WHAT WE
BALANCE IN THAT WITH IN YOU KNOW
OTHER LEGISLATION BECAUSE THE
END IF WE ALL AGREE OF GOTTA GET
HEALTH CARE COSTS REDUCED RIGHT --
IN THE CASE OF PREDICTION AND
LAST THE AUTHORS.
GUILD CURRENTLY HOUSES THAT
COVERED BETWEEN MEDICARE HEALTH
MEDICARE AND PRIVATE INSURANCE
IS EVERYONE HAVE COVERAGE ON
PREDICTION.
ON I HOPE YOU A TREATMENT --
DICTION TREATMENT YEAH.
I CAN ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
SOME OF THE CLINICS OTHER
PROVIDERS CAN TELL YOU BUT I I
WILL SAY THAT. FOR FOR THE COST
IF YOU'RE GETTING A PAIN CLING
THAT SICK PRETTY CLEAR. 195% OF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AFTER THE
FOUR WHEEL CARE ACT.
HAVE SOME TYPE OF INSURANCE MAN
I'LL BE ALWAYS BE ABLE SEE IF
PROVIDERS AS YOU KNOW.
BUT WHEN THEY GET A PRESCRIPTION
THEY HAVE A COPAY SO TO
TRADITIONAL COPAY TWENTY BUCKS
SO 95% OF PEOPLE.
WHO ARE UTILIZING THAT MENTIONED
EARLIER?
A MOM WHO GOES IN FOR LABOR
DELIVERY CELL 95% OF PEOPLE IN
THAT SITUATION ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE.
THEIR THEIR THEIR MEDICINE
PROVIDED FOR THEM.
AND WE BORN WITHIN THE COPAY AND
I WILL NOTE THAT A LOT OF TALK
TODAY ABOUT PASSED THROUGH.
THE PEOPLE THAT.
THERE ARE IT IN INTO THE ROAD OF
THAT COAT THERE THE INSURANCE
FOLKS.
AND THEY'RE NOT HERE IN
OPPOSITION SO THIS REALLY IS I
THINK MORE OF THE PHILOSOPHIC
ARGUED SOME PEOPLE OPPOSE
BECAUSE TWENTY THREE MILLION
PRESCRIPTIONS A YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR FINE
NO ROUGHLY -- TWO BUCKS PURSE
PRESCRIPTION IS THAT GOING TO
BREAK THE BANK I DON'T KNOW I
THINK THAT IS A IS A PRICE TO
PAY -- FOR ALL THE BILLIONS
NOTED EARLIER THAT WE'RE PAYING
CALIFORNIA TO PAY FOR THIS
CRISIS.
THE AGENCY RESPONSE I'D I DON'T.
NEED IT TO KINDA LAMBERT ON THE
QUESTION FURTHER.
I REALIZE THAT FORMA AND KIND OF
THE THE RICH PROFITS -- THAT
THEY ENJOY IT TIMES HE IS A GOOD
BOGEYMAN IN POLITICS.
BUT THE PROBLEM SEEMS FAR MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT AND THAT.
YOU'RE EVERYBODY'S GOT KIND OF A
SEAT AT THE TABLE AND DRIVING
COSTS UP AND EVERYBODY OUT OF
THE SEAT AT THE TABLE DRIVE
COSTS DOWN.
AND THAT'S REALLY -- IN A WERE
MIKE MY QUESTIONS REPORT AND
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO ENSURE THAT.
WE ARE EFFECTIVELY PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT WE BEING THE
LEGISLATURE -- THIS COMMITTEE
AND OTHERS YEAH I READ IN THE
ANALYSIS HERE AND THANK YOU TO
THE STAFF FOR AND WELL DONE
COMEDIAN HOUSES BUT IN THIS.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN
REPORTER THE STATE UNDER SAYING
THAT.
WE ARE WE'VE GOT FUNDS AT DID
SHE ASKED AND PASS ON THE
COUNTIES WERE WERE SITTING ON
THE COUNTIES ARE SET ON TO EARN
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS.
WELL AND SO THAT WOULD ESTABLISH
ANOTHER FUN FOR ANOTHER HUNDRED
MILLION WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE
THAT'S THAT AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO SAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE COVERAGE AND CARE.
UNLESS MAYBE YOU LIVE IN A RURAL
YOU KNOW PART OF THE STATE WHERE
THERE'S NOT THE PROVIDERS THE
PROGRAMS RIGHT -- AND HOW ARE WE
INSURING AGAIN THAT ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE I UNDERSTAND THE BILL HOW
WE'RE ENSURING THAT -- THAT
FOREIGN COUNTRIES HAVE SU TABLE
AND FRANKLY I THINK THAT MAY BE
AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD BUT I
CERTAINLY DON'T THINK WE'VE GOT
OUR ARMS AROUND THE ENTIRE THE
PROBLEM OR THE ENTIRETY OF THE
FOLKS THAT I TO BE AT THE TABLE.
AND ALSO BECAUSE WE KEEP DEALING
WITH THESE ISSUES IN SILOS.
RATHER SIT DOWN AND PUT IN A
REAL PACKAGE OF REFORM TOGETHER
THAT KIND OF HOLDS EVERYBODY
SPEAK TO THE FIRE JUST DOESN'T
STRIKE ME AS THE RIGHT APPROACH
IT WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE THERE.
WHICH ALSO YEAH GOOD JUST HOW WE
AMENDED IT AND THEN I WENT
MISTER GALLAGHER TALK ABOUT THE
IMPACT ON REAL.
IS THAT WE HAD CONCERNS LIKE YOU
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MENTAL HEALTH
ACT THESE COUNTIES ARE SITTING
ON MONEY SO WE DIDN'T WANT THE
MONEY GOING OUT AS A PRIOR
VERSION JUST TO COUNTIES BECAUSE
THEY MAY JUST DO THAT.
WE BROUGHT UP NOW SO -- CLINICS
IN PROVIDERS IN YOUR COMMUNITIES
CAN DIRECTLY APPLY FOR IT -- IN
ADDITION TO COUNTY SEAT LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE -- SO THERE WAS A
LOT IN THERE BUT I'VE BEEN JUST
A COUPLE THINGS THAT I WOULD
RESPOND TO IS -- ONE IT WHAT HAS
HELPED GET OUT INTO THE RURAL
AREAS IS THIS HUB AND SPOKE
MODEL THAT.
I WAS REALLY STARTED TO FEDERAL
FUNDS -- THAT IS HELPING GET
BASICALLY SUPPORT CLINICS GOING
INTO GOING OUT INTO A RULER AND
THEN STE AND THEN ESSENTIALLY
SPOKE IN OFF OF THE HUB SO --
FOR EXAMPLE AGES WHICH IS OF A
PRIVATE COMPANY BUT IS IN THIS
SPACE SAYS USE THOSE FUNDS. TO
ESTABLISH -- CLINICS IN RED
BLUFF YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT --
AND IS HOPING TO USE THAT
CONTINUE THAT HUB AND SPOKE
MODEL TO CONTINUE TO GET IT OUT.
AND TO ALL THE AREAS -- BUT THAT
MONEY IS IS DWINDLING AWAY IT'S
NOT GONNA BE HERE LONG TERM WE
DO NEED TO HAVE A CONTINUOUS
SOURCE OF FUNDING AND SO I SEE
THIS.
AS A WAY TO DO THAT -- AND I
AGREE LIKE THIS ISN'T THE ONLY
SOLUTION BUT YOU KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT ARE BEING
DONE.
YOU KNOW LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF
PILLS -- HAVING DRUG TAKE BACK
PROGRAMS ALL THESE THINGS ARE
GOOD.
RIGHT BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE
DAMAGE IS ALREADY DONE PEOPLE
ARE ALREADY ADDICTED TO THIS
STUFF OKAY SO THAT THAT KIND OF
HELPS.
YOU KNOW KINDA HEAD YOU KNOW
HEADS THE IS A TOURNIQUET READ
IT KIND OF KEEPS IT FROM
SPREADING MORE.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WE
HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE WHO ALREADY
ADDICTED THE ONLY WAY TO REALLY
DEAL WITH US TO GET THEM OFF OF
YOU KNOW NOT ADDICTED ANYMORE
RIGHT WHICH IS A MORE EXPENSIVE
PROBLEM -- AND THAT'S WHERE THIS
FUNDING AND TRYING TO GET MORE
MORE THESE TREATMENT TREATMENTS
AVAILABLE MAKE THEM MORE
WIDESPREAD.
HIS CELL PHONE TO THIS POINT THE
OTHER PEOPLE THAT.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE DEALT WITH
DOCTORS AND PRESCRIBING WE HAVE
DEALT WITH A LOT OF THESE OTHER
AREAS.
THE GROUP THAT HASN'T REALLY
DONE MUCH ON THIS IS THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY THAT
MANUFACTURES AND SO. TO ME AND
SAYING HEY YOU KNOW THE PUBLIC'S
DOING A LOT THE LOCALS ARE DOING
A LOT -- PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
ARE DOING A LOT.
HOW ABOUT YOU GUYS DO A LITTLE
BIT ON THIS AS WELL RISING
HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE A HUGE
ISSUE AND IT'S PROBABLY BIGGER
THAN JUST THIS DISCUSSION RIGHT
HERE?
BUT WHAT I SEE IS THAT
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY WERE
LIMITING.
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE LIMIT HOW
MUCH YOU CAN REIMBURSE THAT MEDI
CAL ALL THOSE THINGS RIGHT WE'RE
WE'RE LIMóN A LOT OF THINGS
WE'RE NOT REALLY LIMITING WHAT
YOU CAN CHARGE FOR PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS.
LAST I CHECKED -- SO.
YOU KNOW IT IN THAT SPACE AND A
AND AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
NESTLE SHOULD GET INTO THAT
RIGHT BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
GOING IN THERE AND TELLING THEM
WHAT THEY CAN CHARGE.
THAT SET SEVENTEEN WAS PURELY A
TRANSPARENCY BILL IF YOU'RE
GOING TO RAISE THE PRICE.
YEAH BUT MORE THAN 16% THEN HEY
YOU SHOULD PROBABLY TELL
EVERYBODY THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
DO THAT RIGHT -- SO THEY CAN
PREPARE FOR THOSE INCREASING
COSTS -- BUT THAT'S THE THE
RISING HEALTHCARE COSTS THAT
ISSUE IS.
IS NOT JUST.
NO THAT'S NOT GONNA BE IMPACTED
BY THIS BILL RIGHT HERE.
IT'S IMPACTED BY A WHOLE HOST OF
OTHER FACTORS.
THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH RIGHT --
AND SO.
YOU KNOW I WOULDN'T TAG.
THAT WHOLE PROBLEM ON ON THIS
ONE BILL WHERE ARE YOU KNOW AS
HE SAID A LOT OF EVERYBODY'S IN
YEARS IN THE CAT THE COST IS
GOING TO GET PASSED ON TO US OR
TO US OR TO WHICH ONE IS IT.
YOU KNOW I THINK THE REALITY IS
INSURANCE IS ACTUALLY THE ONE
WHO PICKS UP MOST OF THE COST OF
THIS.
AND IF IT WAS THAT HUGE OF A
DRIVER TO THEM I WOULD THINK
THEY WOULD BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PEOPLE IN HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THE FACT THEY'RE NOT I THINK IS
A IS A PRETTY TELLING POINT.
I THANK YOU [inaudible]
FOR IDENTIFIED.
AGAIN A MARKER BLAME THE ENTIRE
RISING COST OF HEALTHCARE ON THE
GALLAGHER BILL.
BUT PARTY GO.
THE THE GALLAGHER MCCARTY BOB
JUST LIKE YOU SAYING THAT -- BUT
BUT I DO THINK IT'S IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE NOT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE TO CONTRIBUTOR TOWARDS RIGHT --
INCREASE HEALTHCARE COSTS EVEN
IF IT'S IN A NOBLE.
DEED OR A NOBLE ACTIVITY THAT
WE'RE IT'S MORE MONEY IN THE POT.
AND YOU DIDN'T ADDRESS IN YOUR
ANSWER ALL DOCTORS TO GET YOUR
OPINION BECAUSE YOU AND I HAVE A
DISTRICTS THAT ARE BOTH RURAL IN
NATURE -- WHAT ABOUT THE
PROVIDER ISSUE ARE YOU SATISFIED
THERE'S ADEQUATE?
HELP IN THIS SPACE -- OUT -- ROE
VERSUS YOU KNOW MORE ABOUT WHEN
YOU SAY PROVIDER DO YOU MEAN I
MEAN BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE A DOCTOR.
ALL RIGHT NINE EIGHT AND BUT I
THINK THAT'S PART OF WHERE THIS
FUNDING IS GOING TO IS.
THE THE GOAL THAT IS TO HIRE
MORE PEOPLE IN THE DRUG
TREATMENT SPACE THOSE COULD BE.
DOC SAY COULD BE YOU KNOW.
DRUG TREATMENT SPECIALISTS --
LIKE I SAID THERE'S ACTUALLY IN
LISA MY DISTRICT IT'S MORE OF
THIS THIS PRIVATE SPACES TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE MONEY IN.
AN EXPANDING EN EN.
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE YOU KNOW --
BUT IN ORDER TO DO SO THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
FUNDING SO THEY CAN HIRE.
THOSE PEOPLE AN OPEN THE AND
OPEN THE CLINICS TO MAKE.
MAKE THAT TREATMENT AVAILABLE --
SO I I I REALLY T<c.cyan> THE</c>
FUNDING TO THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE. TO HAVE MORE ACCESS.
TO DRUG TREATMENT PROVIDERS --
AND YOU KNOW E CAN GET INTO THE
THE WHOLE OTHER ISSUE OF LIKE
HEY DO WE NEED.
NO NOT MORE NURSE PRACTITIONERS
AND KNOWS IT IS WHO CAN
PRESCRIBE.
CERTAIN MEDICATIONS THAT'S
ANOTHER THING THAT WE'VE TRIED
TO DEAL WITH THAT I THINK WE DID
PASSED LEGISLATION LAST YEAR --
THAT DEALT WITH THAT ISSUE --
BUT I DO CONNECT THE TWO AND
THAT THIS WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
TO INSURING MORE ACCESS FOR
APPRECIATE PRODUCTION PRECISELY
MY POINT IS THAT THERE'S A
NUMBER OF ISSUES MOVING FORWARD
ON A PARALLEL TRACK HERE THAT --
THEY MAYBE NEED TO BE CONSIDERED --
IN CONCERT.
AND THAT'S KIND OF MY POINT --
TOWARD YOUR BILL IS NOT THAT
THIS COULD BE PIECES SOLUTION
BUT WE CERTAINLY HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE OTHER -- THE OTHER SPOKES ON
A WHEEL THERE AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'RE DOING THAT AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S ONLY IN THESE
MOMENTS WHEN BILLS ARE UP FOR
VOTES THAT WE GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO APPLY THAT PRESSURE -- TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT RIGHT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE WE HEAR OVER TO TAKE
CARE THAT OTHER PROBLEM LATER.
AND LATER NEVER COMES RIGHT AND
THOSE OF US LIBERAL COMMUNITIES
AND HOW MANY TIMES WE EXPANDED --
MEDI CAL AND IN ALL KINDS OF
MAJOR INCREASES IN FUNDING AND
WE DO NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PROVIDER SHORTAGE IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND WILL SOLVE YOUR PROBLEM WE
GET THE NEXT BILLION AND THEN
THE NEXT BILLION NEVER COMES SO --
AGAIN WHILE I SUPPORT WHAT YOU
GUYS ARE ATTEMPTING TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS IN IN THIS BILL
AND I THINK THERE'S A MAJOR
EPIDEMIC HERE AND I AND I
COMMEND YOU FOR TAKING IT ON I
DON'T THINK I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT.
YOUR BILL TODAY I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD LAY OFF LEAVE OPEN THE
POSSIBILITY THAT I CAN SUPPORT
THIS TOMORROW -- BUT I WANT TO
ENGAGE IN.
SOME MORE THOROUGH DISCUSSIONS
ON THESE TOPICS SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE SOLVING THE
WHOLE PROBLEM -- AND NOT JUST
SHIFTING.
THE PROBLEM AROUND.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS. FOR THAT
THEY THE LOCKERS. FOR BRINGING
THIS TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE.
OF YOU I HAD ONE QUESTION YOU'D
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT THERE WAS
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT WILL END IN.
TWENTY TWENTY WAS THIS FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
PROGRAMS.
FOR THESE PEOPLE OR CORRECT.
AT TWO FOLD -- ONE EVEN IF THE
FEDERAL MONEY.
DIDN'T RUN OUT WHICH RIGHT NOW
THE FOLKS AT CONGRESS ARE SAYING
WE HADN'T TOLD TWENTY TWENTY AND
WHO KNOWS THAT.
NEXT ELECTIONS AND PRESIDENT SO
FORTH.
OUR WITNESSES EARLIER OUR OUR
TESTIFYING THAT THEY COULD
DRAMATICALLY USE MORE MONEY ON
TOP OF THE FEDERAL MONEY RIGHT
NOW THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
BEING SERVED IN THIS.
HUB AND SPOKE MODEL WHO DON'T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET.
THIS COMMITTEE TREATMENT TO TO
TO GET OFF.
THIS DEADLY DISEASE -- BUT YES --
THE WE WE ARE ANTICIPATING THAT
IT WOULD RUN OUT.
AND IF THIS MEASURE BECAME LAW
THE MONEY TO START COMING IN
LITERALLY THE SAME YEAR THAT
RUNS OUT BECAUSE THIS IS.
IMPLEMENTED -- GET THE OUT YEAR
PLUS ONE SO IT ACTUALLY OP TIES
UP -- NICELY.
OKAY WELL -- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
AND YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TO SEE
THIS DISCUSSION CONTINUE YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES
REYES TODAY -- BUT I THINK THAT.
IF WE CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
I HOPE TO SEE.
OF THOSE RESOLVED THAN US TO
MOVE FORWARD IN A WAY THAT WILL
HELP -- THE PEOPLE.
THAT -- ADDICTED THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I SEEN AND I HAVE SOME -- I'M
SORRY MR GRAY LEFT BECAUSE THEY
DO.
I DO THINK THAT THIS THAT AS AN
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE WE HAVE
WORKED ON THE FRONT AND LIKE YOU
SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER I%
THINK WE'VE LOOKED AT HOW DO WE
SLOW THE BLEEDING ON THE
SITUATION BUT WE HAVEN'T SPENT
ACTUALLY AS MUCH TIME ON
ADDICTION.
AND THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY
ADDICTED -- I AM A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED BY SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY OF THE OPPOSITION I'M
TO SAY BUSINESS AS USUAL IS OKAY
IS CLEARLY NOT THE CASE AND A
LOT OF OUR DISTRICTS WHERE WE
HAVE MORE UPDATE PROJECT
PRESCRIPTIONS THEN WE HAVE
PEOPLE -- AND I THINK THERE'S A
REAL CONCERN AND THERE'S A REAL
NEED TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT I
DON'T THINK THE INTENTION OF THE
BUT THIS BILL IS TO HAVE
PHARMACISTS TAKE ON THIS BURDEN
EIGHT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S THE INTENTION AND I'M
SURE.
THE OTHERS WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS TO TO ASSURE THAT --
THREE OUT OF FOUR TEENAGERS
BEGIN THEIR HER WAY INTO HEROIN
ADDICTION WITH A PRESCRIPTION
OPIOID.
IN THEIR HOME AND UP UP CLEARLY
THAT WAS PRESCRIBED TO THEM BY A
DOCTOR.
SO THIS IS A SERIOUS EPIDEMIC
AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE SERIOUS
WORK TO CREATE A SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM AND I DO AGREE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY THAT THIS
IS NOT THE TOTAL SOLUTION.
HOWEVER WE NEED FUNDS WE NEED
FUNDS FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES WE
NEED FUNDS FOR CLINICS.
AND ALTHOUGH NOT THE PERFECT
SOLUTION I DO THINK THIS IS A
STEP FORWARD AND CONVERSATION
AND A SOLUTION FOR ADDICTION.
NOT THE COMPLETE PROBLEM --
THERE ARE CROP COST DRIVERS --
BUT WE ALL DO PAY FOR OPIATE
ADDICTION.
WHETHER IT IS IN OUR HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUMS ARE IN STATE
FUNDS I MEDI CAL WE ALL PAY FOR
IT.
SO TO ELIMINATE MANUFACTURERS
FROM PAYING FOR IT I THINK IT'S
UNREALISTIC AT THIS POINT.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I I JUST -- APPRECIATE THAT THE
DEBATE HERE IN THIS IS NOT
ALWAYS AN EASY -- CONVERSATION
HAVE ABOUT IT -- CHARGING A FEE
I I DON'T THINK IT'S A TAX IT'S
NOT A CERTAINLY NOT A JOB KILLER
ANY PRODUCTS WHAT WE KNOW.
SOMETHING ON THE OTHER NATIVE
HAPPENS AND YOU OUTLINED IT
THERE IS THAT -- YEAH THIS IS
NOT GOING TO SOLVE THE FEDERAL
CRISIS AND I CAN KERR BUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE HOOKED ON FENNEL STARTED
BECAUSE THEY EVERY ABUSING PAIN
KILLERS.
AND THE INDUSTRY HAS
RESPONSIBILITY STEP UP AS PART
OF THE SOLUTION.
YEAH WOULD YOU SAID THIS IS IT I
THINK AS YOU OUTLINE I MEAN THIS
IS A VERY UNIQUE SITUATION --
AND IT IS A VERY UNIQUE CRISIS.
YEAH I'M CERTAINLY NOT THE ONE
THAT'S ALWAYS.
STEPPING UP TO SAY HEY WE SHOULD
HAVE MORE FEES OR OR A YOU KNOW.
BUT IN THIS CASE WITH ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE KNOW AND
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
AND ALL THE THINGS WE'VE ALREADY
DONE.
I THINK IT IS WARRANTED -- AND
IT JUST SAYS HEY YOU KNOW.
MANUFACTURES BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
TO GET PEOPLE OFF OF THIS.
OF THESE DRUGS THAT WE NEED TO
DEAL WITH WITH THE ADDICTION.
AND ME TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
ADDICTION IS IS AS I SAID LAST
COMMITTEE ADDICTION IS THE
BIGGEST JOB KILLER -- WHEN I'VE
SEEN YOU KNOW PEOPLE GET
ADDICTED TO THESE DRUGS AND NOT
BE ABLE?
TO LIVE PRODUCTIVE LIVES -- AND
THAT HURTS YOUR ECONOMY THAT
HURTS.
YOUR LOCAL -- INDUSTRIES -- IT
HURTS YOUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PUBLIC SAFETY.
YOUR HOSPITALS ALL ACROSS THE
BOARD SO.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING I THINK
THIS IS IS THIS BILL IS NEEDED
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THIS HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL.
I WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MS HIGHLY CALDERON [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE AYE AYE BRO.
BRUNO CHIU.
YOU ARE A GRAY MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING MELINDA'S.
MULLIN DOES NOT VOTING MULLIN
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HI BURKE I RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE TING TING [inaudible]
UNCLE.
THAT'S ON CALL IT NEEDS ONE MORE
VOTE.
DO YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
OTHER TEAM [inaudible]
THESE.
TWO I RETURNING TO FILE ITEM ONE
AB ONE THIRTY SIX I NEED THANK
YOU I NEED A SECOND.
MS HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
BURKE HI.
BURKE I THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
BRO I CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY.
MAYES.
FILE ITEM.
ONE AB ONE THIRTY SIX DAYS.
NOT VOTING MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK OUR WORK I
RIVAS.
RIVAS I TING.
TNG I THAT BILLS OUT THAT BILLS
OUT MOVING A FILE ITEM TO AB TEN
TWENTY SEVEN MINUTES.
THANK YOU.
A SECOND.
I WANT TO THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BRO.
WELL I TO CHU AYE GRAY MAYES.
MAYES I AM OLYMPUS.
MELINDA'S EINMAL IN [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I RIVAS [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING ON MOVING TO FILE ITEM --
THREE THAT BILLS OUT -- MOVING
TO FILE ITEM THREE AB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PRO WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN AS MOVE
THE BILL CREATES ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SINCE WE HAVE A MOTION SECOND IT
BASICALLY RATES A AN ACCOUNT FOR
PEOPLE TO PUT MONEY INTO IT TAX
FREE FOR DOWN PAYMENT ON A HOME.
LAST ROBERT WITH ME TODAY IS
MICHAEL GUNNING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS -- MIND
GETTING CB I A HERE IN SUPPORT
WE'VE DUBBED -- AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN AS A HOUSING CREATOR
WE THINK THIS PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS TO SAVE THE MONEY TO
PURCHASE HOMES WE HELP IT DEALS
WE WE THINK IT THAT DEALS WITH
THE HOUSING CRISIS.
AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
NAME FOR JONES THANK YOU CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA HONOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN OUT SORRY MR TEAM.
YOU DID MENTION THE INCOME THERE
ARE THEIR INCOME RESTRICTIONS IN
THE BILL.
YES AS AMENDED IN THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE ON SARS WHERE AND WHAT
OTHER -- ME JUST 80% OF THE
ADJUSTED MEDIUM HOME VALUE.
BUT INCOME FOR THE PEOPLE AND
OTHER VALUE AS WELL AS ONE OF
THE SUGGEST OKAY.
WHAT'S THE INCOME WAS THE INCOME
80% OF ADJUSTED MEDIAN INCOME
GRAPHIC.
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
JUST.
TRAVEL.
AS THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS JUST TO
CONFIRM WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW.
MISSILE ME CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE.
AYE BRO.
BRO I TO CHIU AYE GRAY MAYES.
MAYES ARI MELINDA'S WILL IN THIS
I AM MULLIN.
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
QUIRK.
BURKE I RIVAS TING.
TING ON IT'S OUT.
THAT BILL IS OUT MOVING TO THE
BILL ONLY ITEMS -- WILL START AT
YEAH BECAUSE WE JUST HAVE.
BECAUSE MR GREAT [inaudible] SIX
WE WE KNOW FILE ITEM SIX AB TEND
TO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
PLEASE.
THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S MELINDA'S
I'M MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK I RIVAS KING.
THIS IS OUR SPONSORS I AM SIX AB
TENT YOU [inaudible]
TING ON BILLS THAT BILL IS OUT
MOVING A VIOLATE THEM SEVEN AB.
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE I
ROLE.
CHU.
CHU ON A GRAY MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S.
WELL IN THIS NOT VOTING MULLIN
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK
[inaudible]
I RIVAS.
TING.
TING ONLINE.
THAT BILLS OUT LIVING A FILE
ITEM AB SIXTY SIX AND SALAS ARE
THE MOST.
YEAH THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BRO. TWO CHEW ON A GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES ON MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN.
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK.
WORK I RIVAS TING.
TING ON WITHOUT THAT BILL IS OUT
MOVING A FILE ITEM NINE AB.
TWO SIXTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS TO AYE.
AND AFTER I HAVE A MOTION.
YEAH.
EVEN MOTION I'M A MOTION TO HAVE
A SECOND.
I'M AB [inaudible]
TWO SIXTY SIX WE AS FAR AWAY
COLORADO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO A PROFI APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE BRO BRO I TO CHIU AYE
GRAY MAYES.
MAYES I'M MELINDA'S MELINDA'S
I'M MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS. THREE
DOORS I QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING RIVAS TING --
TING NOT LOADING.
THE BILL SO THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TEN AB FOUR
OH FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WAS HIGHLY COLORADO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BURKE HI BURKE AYE BRO.
REAL AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY MAYES.
MAYES HI MELINDA THIS MULLIN
DESIGN MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT LOADING RIVAS TANG.
TING NOT LOADING.
THE BILL IS OUT MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
TRAVEL MOTION AND SECOND.
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE HI BURKE AYE BRO.
WELL I TO CHEW ON A GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES I'M MELINDA'S LINDA'S I
MULLIN.
PETRIE NORRIS.
DOORS ARE AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT LOADING RIVAS.
TING [inaudible]
TING I IT'S A FABULOUS OUT.
LIVE IN A FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
SEVEN FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS TO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
AS I UP ITEM BY ITEM TWELVE A.
B.. SEVEN FORTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE HI
BRO.
BRO ALL RIGHT. TO TO OUR AYE
GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES ARM MELINDA'S.
ALLEN THIS NOT VOTING MULLIN.
PETRIE NORRIS. THREE NORTH ARE
AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT LOADING RIVAS.
TEN TING NOT VOTING.
SOUND QUALITY THAT'S ON CALL IT
NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE MOVING A
FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN AB.
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MS HIGHLAND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AHRI BRO.
BRO ALRIGHT CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY.
MAYES MAYES I'M MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S I MULLIN.
PETRIE NORRIS.
BETWEEN YOURS I QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT LOADING RIVAS TANG.
ARE TING HI.
SOUTH THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVING A FILE AND FOURTEEN AB
SEVEN NINETY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS --
HOWEVER THE AUTHOR IS COMMITTED
TO TAKE THE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS AND APPROPRIATIONS SO.
THERE ARE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRILL I CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S BELINDA'S I
MULLIN PETRIE NORRIS.
VETERAN OURS AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK I RIVAS TING.
TING THE BILL SO THAT THOSE OUT.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB.
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO THE MODE THE
MOTION THANK YOU THE MOTION IS
TO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE WORLD.
ARE YOU.
TO CHIU I GRAY.
MAYES MAYES I'M MELINDA THIS.
MELINDA I'M MULLIN.
PETRIE NORRIS BUT YOU NORTH ARE
QUIRK.
QUIRK I RIVAS [inaudible]
YEP YEAH.
QUIRK I AM FIFTEEN I RIVAS TING.
CHIANG ARE THAT BILLS OUT.
THAT BILL IS OUT MOVING A FILE
AND SIXTEEN AB.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT I HAVE A
MOTION. TWENTY SECONDS.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO -- RIGHT.
TO CHIU AYE GRAY.
MAYES MAYES AYE AMYLIN THIS.
MULLIN DOES NOT VOTING.
MOLEN.
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT LOADING RIVAS TING
[inaudible]
TING I WITHOUT THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVING A FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
ELEVEN TWENTY THEM.
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRILL I CHIU.
CHIU I GRAY MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN JUST
OUTLINED MULLIN.
PATRON NORRIS BETWEEN ORDERS ARE
AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK HI RIVAS KING.
CHIANG NOT VOTING.
ABOUT.
THAT BILLS OUT MOVING TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB ELEVEN SIXTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE HOWEVER THE
OTHER IS COMMITTED TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND APPROPRIATIONS
DELAYING THE CREDIT -- TIRES
MADE ON OR AFTER JANUARY FIRST
[inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO ARE YOU CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY.
MAYES MAYES AYE MELINDA'S LANDIS
I'M MULLIN.
PETRIE NORRIS.
PETITIONERS AYE AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK I RIVAS TANG.
HI THAT BILL SO THAT BILLS OUT
MOVING A FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS. TO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AHRI BRO.
BRO ON EACH YOU.
CHIU I GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES ARE AYE MELINDA THIS
WINDOWS ARE MULLIN.
PETRIE NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK.
QUIRK I RIVAS TING.
KING ARE THAT BILLS.
A BILL IS OUT.
MOVING A FILE ITEM TWENTY AB.
TWELVE FIFTY NINE OTHER MOTIONS
TO PASTOR PREPARATION I HAVE A
MOTION THANK YOU AND A SECOND
MISSILE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE AYE
BURKE AYE BRO.
BRILL AYE CHU.
CHU I'D GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I
MULLIN.
PATRICK NORRIS.
VETERAN OURS I QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT LOADING RIVAS TANG.
TING ARE THAT BILLS OUT THAT
BILL IS OUT.
MOVING A FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
FIFTEEN FORTY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
HOWEVER THE AUTHOR IS COMMITTED
TO TAKE A MOMENT IN
APPROPRIATION REDUCING THE
CREDIT PERCENTAGE 230% AND
ELIMINATING THE DOUBLE DIPPING
DO I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
TO HAVE A SECOND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRILL I CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY I MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN.
PETRIE NORRIS.
VETERAN OURS ARE QUIRK.
QUIRK I RIVAS CHIANG.
TING I THAT BILL SO THAT BILLS
OUT.
WHERE FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN NINETY OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASTOR PREPARATION --
HOWEVER THE OTHER HAS COMMITTED
TO TAKE AND THEM IT'S
APPROPRIATION TO LEADING THE
MILEAGE METRIC TO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
YEAH AND I REMEMBER WHAT THIS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
YES BECAUSE SHE HAD PART OF THE
PROVISIONS WAS THE WAS THE
DISTANCE RIGHT ESTIMATING
ESTIMATED MILEAGE YEAH.
DO I REMOTE -- DRIVE A SECOND I
HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND.
THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
REAL AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY I MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I'M MULLIN.
HATCHERY NORRIS.
BUT YOU NORTH ARE AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT LOADING RIVAS KING.
TING NOT LOADING [inaudible]
WITHOUT THAT.
THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE AYE
BURKE AYE BRAILLE.
WELL I TO TO OUR AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MAYES.
MAYES I'M MELINDA'S.
MULLIN DESIGN MULLIN PETRIE
NORRIS.
BETWEEN NORTH AYE AYE QUIRK.
I RIVAS CHIANG.
CHING I THAT BILL SO THAT BILLS
OUT MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- THE AUTHOR HAS
COMMITTED TAKE A MOMENT AND
APPROPRIATIONS RECASTING THE
EXEMPTION AS AN OPTIONAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMMING
AUTHORIZING TAX REBATES DO I
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND YEAH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO I CHU.
CHU GRAY.
GRAY AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN.
GIVE ME MELENDEZ AYE.
MULLIN [inaudible]
PETRIE NORRIS. THREE NORTH AYE
QUIRK.
QUIRK I RIVAS TING.
TING EITHER BILLS OUT.
BILLS OUT FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MOVE.
A SILENT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO I TO DO I GRAY [inaudible]
GRAY ARMIES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S MELINDA'S
ARM MULLIN.
PETRIE NORRIS.
BUT YOU NOR IS AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT LOADING RIVAS TING.
TING I THAT BILL SO THAT BILL IS
OUT -- RETURNING TO THE REGULAR
ORDER OF BUSINESS MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FIVE AB SIXTEEN OH SIX MR
GREY WOULD YOU LIKE TO FOR THAT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB
SIXTY NO SIX IS A FOLLOW UP BILL
WHICH WAS A FOLLOW UP TO A BILL
WHICH WAS SIGNED LAST YEAR TO
CREATE A FUN WITHIN THE STATE
TREASURY. TO SERVICE DOWN THERE
FOR THE CREATION OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
SCHOOL IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WAR UNVEILED ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE MEMBERS MAY HAVE --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
THE COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
DOCTOR QUIRK.
SO.
HOW DO YOU HANDLE PROFESSIONAL
GAMBLERS AND HOW DO YOU DEFINE
IT SO THAT ANYBODY WHO HAS A
LOSS TO US DOESN'T FIND THEM?
JUST DECIDES THEIR PROFESSIONAL
GAMBLER.
WE'VE ENGAGES WITH DISCUSSIONS --
TRYING TO GET AFTER THE
PROFESSIONAL ISSUE AS IT RELATES
TO WORLD SERIES OF POKER AND
SOME OF TOUCH VETS HAVE ARRIVED.
YOU KNOW AT THAT CONCLUSION I
THINK IT'S DIFFICULT TO YOUR
POINT -- DEFINED IN SUCH A
FASHION THAT YOU DON'T.
YOUR OVERLY BROAD.
HINTS AND AND BRING IN A BOOK OF
THAT KIND OF LEISURE GAMBLING
MONEY WHICH FRANKLY I THINK IS
TOTALLY INAPPROPRIATE AS A WRITE
OFF ME TO COST -- THE STATE'S
ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR --
IN REVENUE ON TOP OF THE FACT
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT JUST
EXPANDED.
THE RIGHT OFF SO SOME OF THAT
PROFESSIONAL QUESTION MAY GET
ANSWERED IN AS WE GET THE
ANALYSIS FROM THE FROM THE FEDS
ON HOW MUCH OF AN EXPANSION AND
HOW THAT -- SAID CHANTING GLOBE
WITH THAT WITH OUR BILL.
GREAT I'M CERTAINLY WILLING TO
SUPPORT IT TO YOU CAN GET IT
DONE THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
ANY -- MYSTERIES.
I WAS ACTUALLY GOING -- TO TO
MOVE THIS THINKING BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF NOT
HAVING ENOUGH DOCTORS IN.
IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT AS SOMEBODY WHO USED TO
PREPARE TAXES -- I WAS SHOCKED
AT THE NUMBER OF OF INDIVIDUALS --
WHO WOULD COME IN WITH TEN
NINETY NINES IN FACT SOMETIMES
ROLES OF TEN NINETY NINES?
I'M YOU'D HAVE -- WE HAD A LOT
OF NURSES THAT WOULD -- FIND
THEMSELVES GAMBLING I'M QUITE A
BIT OF THOSE WHO IS A NICHE OF
BUSINESS THAT I HAD.
AND IT ALMOST ALWAYS IF THEY HAD
FIFTY SIXTY SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF INCOME ALMOST ALWAYS
THEY HAD FIFTY SIXTY SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF LOSSES
COURSE MAKE PERFECT SENSE -- THE
FOR THAT TO BE THE CASE AND SO
WOULD BE DIFFICULT WITHOUT THAT
AND FOR ME IT WILL SUPPORT THAT.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE REVENUE
WOULD BE USED FOR WHICH THERE IS
A DEFINITE NEED -- BUT JUST
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF FOLKS WHO DO GAMBLE AND
THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT LOSSES IN
ESSENCE THEY'RE GONNA BE PAYING
A TAX FOR FOR INCOME THAT
THEY'VE NEVER.
THEY'VE NEVER RECEIVED AND SO
OFTEN THAT TO STAY OFF TODAY.
IT DOES CONCERT I CERTAINLY WAY
THAT QUESTION IN MY MIND --
ARRIVED AT THE CONCLUSION IT
GAMBLING LIKE MANY OTHER FORMS
OF ENTERTAINMENT IS AN
APPROPRIATE -- RIGHT OFF OF
REGARDS SITUATION SO BUT I
APPRECIATE WHERE YOU COME FROM
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. FIFTEEN NOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE LIVELY
DISCUSSION RESPECTFUL CRUSHER
AYE VOTE THANK YOU MANAGER.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND TO HAVE THEM OKAY
WE GOT WE GOT IT -- A TIMELY
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE AYE BRO.
THROW NOT VOTING CHU.
CHU ARE AYE GRAY.
HI RAY AYE MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING MELENDEZ.
MULLIN DOES NOT VOTING MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I QUIRK HI.
I RIVAS TING [inaudible]
TING ONLINE.
DOUBLE THE OUT.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON CALL THE
FIRST IS FILE ITEM FOR AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
MISSILE ONLY CALL THE ABSENTEES
GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MULLIN. FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
MULLIN I NORRIS.
I'M SORRY EXCUSE AS
PETRIE-NORRIS I IT'S THAT BILLS
OUT AND THE OTHER BILL ON CALL
IS FILE ITEM TWELVE AB -- SEVEN
FORTY FIVE IS HIGHLY CALL THE
ABSENT.
RAY HI RAY I MULLIN.
MULLIN I RIVAS.
TING NOT VOTING TO AYE.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT.
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND WE CAN TO ADELINE.
YEAH MIGHT AS WELL.
WE'LL START FROM THE TOP AND DO
ADD ONS FILE ITEM ONE AB
[inaudible]
ONE THIRTY SIX GRAY.
HI RAY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I FILE ITEM TO AB
TEN TWENTY SEVEN GRAY AYE GRAY
AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE-NORRIS.
JUNE ORDERS I MS I TO NOT VOTING
RIVAS OKAY.
FILE ITEM THREE AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN GRAY AYE GRAY AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RIVAS.
I'M OKAY ON FOR FILE ITEM.
FIVE IT'S JUST MISREADING THIS.
SIX WE HAVE ALLEN SIX AB TEN BRO.
BRO I GRAY HI RAY ON A MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RIVAS. SEVEN FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB [inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR PEARL.
BRO KNOWN ALL MAYES.
EXCUSE ME GRAY I APOLOGIZE HI
RAY I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RIVAS. EIGHT FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB SIXTY SIX ROW.
BRO I GRAY AYE GRAY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RIVAS -- NUMBER NINE
FILE ITEM.
NINE GRAY.
HI GRAY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I RIVAS.
TEN FILE A. B. AT TWELVE TEN A.
B..
FOUR OH FIVE RAY HI RAY HI
MULLIN.
MULLIN ONLINE RIVAS [inaudible]
ELEVEN FILE ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY
OUR TWENTY SEVEN GRAY HI RAY
I'M MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RIVAS -- THIRTEEN
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR GRAY.
NOW.
GRAY NOW [inaudible]
MULLIN. ONE ONLINE -- VIOLATE IN
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY ONE
GRAY [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MOON I FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO IS
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
MULLIN. FORTY ONE I GRAY AYE
FIFTEEN FILE ITEM FOURTEEN FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
GRAY ONLINE FILE AND FIFTEEN
GRAY ARE.
GREAT OKAY.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB NINE THIRTY
EIGHT GRAY AYE GRAY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RIVAS BFA NEED
SEVENTY FILE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN GRAY HI GRAY AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RIVAS -- EIGHTEEN I
MEAN EIGHTEEN AB ELEVEN SIXTY
NINE GRAY AYE GRAY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I RIVAS [inaudible]
NINETEEN BALLOT IN NINETEEN AB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN RAY I REALLY
AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RIVAS IN.
TWENTY THOSE ARE [inaudible]
TWENTY THE TWENTY FILE ITEM
TWENTY AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE GRAY
AYE GRAY AYE MULLIN.
WHEN IRIVAS AND? TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE AB.
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO ONE MULLIN I
RIVAS. TWENTY THREE FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE AB SEVENTEEN SEVEN
TWENTY SIX MULLIN [inaudible]
SIX I WAIT A MINUTE OKAY WITH
TWO WHICH IS -- TO I WAS ON
TWENTY TWO I'M SORRY.
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN NINETY FILE
ITEM.
FIFTY TWENTY TWO FIFTY NINE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE RIVAS.
NOW -- 1-726- VIOLATED TWENTY
THREE AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY SIX
MULLIN.
MULLIN I SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR
MULLIN AYE.
AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX MULLIN
[inaudible] ONE I WE HAVE -- WE
DOWN AS A NOT VOTING ON ITEM FOR
GRAY NOT VOTING ITEM
[inaudible]
FOR ITEM.
FOR GRAY IS NOT VOTING THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IT'S REALLY.
YEAH I I TAKE CENTER.
THAT.
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
NEXT FIVE MINUTES.
GOT A STEP [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible] FOR SECOND
VEHICLE.
SAID YES HE WAS AT YEAH. SEVEN
ONE HE WENT UP YES QUIRK WHEN IT.
IF HE DID THIRTY WILL TOMORROW
--
FOUR SIX THREE MORE MINUTES.
MOVING A FILE ITEM TO B TEN
TWENTY SEVEN RIVAS.
RIVAS AHRI FILE ITEM THREE A. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN RIVAS.
RIVAS I FILE ITEM FIVE AB.
SIXTEEN OH SIX RIVAS RIVAS I
FILE ITEM SIX A. B. TEN RIVAS.
RIVAS I FILE SEVEN AB TWENTY
FOUR RIVAS.
RIVAS ARI FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
SIXTY SIX RIVAS.
RIVAS II FILE FILE ITEM NINE AB.
SIXTY SIX RIVAS II I LIVE IN TEN
EIGHTY FOUR OH FIVE RIVAS RIVAS
I FILE ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN RIVAS.
RIVAS I BY ELEVEN TWELVE AB FOUR
SEVEN FORTY FIVE RIVAS.
RIVAS I FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR RIVAS.
RIVAS I FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
SEVEN NINETY ONE RIVAS RIVAS I
VIOLATE IN FIFTEEN AB SEVENTY
TWO RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE BY LATE IN SIXTEEN AB
NINE THIRTY EIGHT RIVAS RIVAS I
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB ELEVEN
TWENTY RIVAS.
RIVAS EYEING MY LATE IN EIGHTEEN
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE RIVAS RIVAS
I'D BY LATE IN NINETEEN AB
TWELVE SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN RIVAS
REEVES I FILE ITEM TWENTY AB
TWELVE FIFTY NINE RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE VIOLENT I'M TWENTY ONE
AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE WHILE IN TWENTY TWO A.
B. FIFTEEN NINETY RIVAS.
RIVAS AYE BY LATE IN AB
SEVENTEEN VIOLATED TWENTY THREE
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY SIX RIVAS --
SCI FI WITHIN TWENTY FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR RIVAS
RIVAS ISLAND AND TWENTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX RIVAS.
RIVERSIDE [inaudible]
WE'RE ADJOURNED